Спекотній літній день сьогодні в місті Львові. Туристи тут і там. Львів’яни ж на природі.
Типовий львів’янин початку 20-го століття.
Петро Радковець щоранку перевтілюється в цей образ, який придумав ще у 80-х роках.
Образ почався з вусів, потім мельойник. Потім образ почав обростати, з’явилася і цибулька.
Тема його екскурсій – історія міста Лева, Західної України. Це улюблений персонаж.
Князь Данило Галицький, за часів якого Галицько-Волинська Русь
пережила період політичного і економічного розквіту.
Князь Данило - це приклад для сучасних політиків.
Сучасних політиків, які так бентежать сьогодні українське суспільство -
Петра Порошенка та Володимира Зеленського, - Петро знає особисто.
У різні часи проводив для них екскурсії.
Це спілкування на тлі ретельного спостереження за українською політикою
для Петра вирішальне і в першому, і в другому турі виборів.
Хоча Петро має до чинного президента багато зауважень
у питаннях мови, оборони і зовнішньої політики –він прихильник Порошенка.
Як і більшість жителів Львівщини, де в першому турі переміг саме чинний президент.
Там, де немає міцної влади, хтось приходить і захоплює землі.
В своїй масі Львівщина - це продержавницький електорат .
А державницькі тенденції полягають в тому, що треба відстоювати національні інтереси.
Національні інтереси не можуть ефективно відстоювати представники "старої політичної еліти ",
вважає водійка таксі Тамара Орліковська.
Вона зізнається, що прихильникам Зеленського у Львові непросто.
Дискусія на тему щодо спроможності несистемної людини керувати державою
може завершитися видаленням з друзів – у реальному і віртуальному житті соцмереж.
Я так думаю, на багатьох повпливали страшні історії,
що якщо людина приходить несистемна, то буде погано.
Львівська молодь обожнює ось такі "демократично-кавові місця".
22-річний Ростислав - студент-айтішнік зізнається,
що дещо втомився від міркувань, хто з кандидатів вартий його голосу.
Він ретельно вивчив їхні "кейси".
Діяльність президента Порошенка студент оцінив не дуже високо.
Це результат, як мінімум, для мене поки прийнятний. На "трійку ".
Але ж і кандидат Зеленський, який часто спілкується російською, тежне варіант.
Мене дуже бентежить і не подобається його позиція в мовному питанні.
Ростислав ще не вирішив, як голосувати 21 квітня.
Як і більшість жителів Львівщини, які у першому турі голосували не за Порошенка чи Зеленського.
Нема нікого нормального, якщо чесно. Що один, що другий. Я ні того, ні того не бачу президентом.
Цей трамвай курсує історичним центром Львова. Вибори нагадують про себе на кожній зупинці.
То "кінець епохи жадібності", то "вирішальний вибір".
Керує трамваєм єдина в Україні водійка-блогерка.
Друзі! вітаю вас на каналі водія трамваю Лідії Филипчук. Третій трамвайний маршрут…
Політика сильно псує ій настрій, зізнається Лідія.
Вірогідність перемоги Зеленського вона сприймає як трагедію.
Я болюче буду переживати. Невідомо кого він приведе до влади і що буде з державою…
Продажі солодощів у львівських рестораціях останнім часом зросли.
Городянам потрібно більше ендорфінів,
аби пережити ці кілька днів до виборів, іронізує власник закладу Андрій Іонов.
Насправді, бізнесмену не весело.
Він не виключає, що Львівщина знов проголосує не так, як решта України,
і готовий поважити вибір більшості.
Але на тему війни на Донбасі та діалогу з Росією
чоловік хотів би вже зараз мати більше конкретики від кандидата Зеленського.
Я нічого не хочу сказати поганого про Зеленського.
Можливо, він геніальна, суперможливість для цієї держави і для мене так саме.
Але доведи мені це! Я поки що лишився без відповідей.
На вулицях Львова активно агітують за кандидатів у президенти.
В кав’ярнях міста Лева час наче зупинився. Незмінне лише минуле.
На що натякає цей кавовий годинник.
Майбутнє воно вже сформовано, але ще можна вплинути.
Гід Петро Радковецьвже смакує момент,
як він буде пити каву по-львівськи і дивитися дебати кандидатів у президенти.
Якщо ж Львівщина буде незадоволена новим президентом, то , каже Петро,
на парламентських виборах це можна буде скоригувати.